Speaker 1: So thanks to some recently released
court documents, we've learned that multiple
of the accused rioters from the January 6th
insurrection attempt tried to use the legal
defense.
Donald Trump made me do it.
Now, they tried, but at least so far, it's
been unsuccessful because the court said no
way.
And in fact, one of the people who tried this
is that guy known as the Kuhnen Shoman, Jacob
Tansley, who was photographed in the House
chamber wearing like a Viking hat of some
kind.
And his lawyer was actually making the case
that what Jacob Tansley did would not have
happened were it not for the words and the
actions of President Donald Trump.
His lawyer said, if it weren't for Trump,
my client, your honor, would never even have
been in Washington, D.C. in support of the
president.
And were it not for the specific words of
the then president on January 6th saying we're
going to march down Pennsylvania Avenue or
whatever, the defendant would not have walked
down Pennsylvania Avenue and would never have
gone near, never mind inside the US Capitol
building saying my client did it because Donald
Trump told him to.
This was part of his lawyer trying to get
him out on bail instead of having him stay
in pretrial detention.
And his lawyer argued he's not dangerous.
He wasn't even sincerely there due to his
own beliefs.
It was just because of Trump.
Trump made him do it.
And the judge in the case, Royce Lamberth,
said, quote, Even taking defendants claim
at face value, it does not persuade the court
that the defendant would not pose a danger
to others if released.
If the defendant truly believes that the only
reason he participated in an assault on the
US Capitol was to comply with President Trump's
orders.
This shows the defendant's inability or refusal
to exercise his independent judgment and conform
his behavior to the law.
In other words, the judge is saying if Trump
really convinced him to do it, it's still
on him.
And that doesn't tell me if I release him,
he won't be a threat because someone else
could convince him to do something such just
as dangerous or stupid.
Whether he believes Trump wants him to do
it has nothing to do with whether his actions
conform with the law.
And you might remember the other version of
this that we talked about think it was a couple
of weeks ago, a defendant's lawyer in another
one of these writers, lawyers, claimed that
the accused was suffering from, quote, Fox
itis and, quote, Fox mania and that it is
Fox News rather than Donald Trump that are
to blame.
Now, big picture, this is not a valid legal
excuse.
Answering someone else's call to break the
law doesn't make it irrelevant that you still
broke the law, but.
There are cases when if someone was really
manipulated or forced into breaking the law,
I mean, in a way, I'm not comparing Trump
to Charles Manson, but when you look at the
Charles Manson case, Charles Manson, if I
recall correctly, this is just occurring to
me now.
If I recall correctly, Charles Manson himself
did not actually kill anyone, but he directed
others to do it.
And yet he was found legally guilty because
he brainwashed, manipulated others, et cetera.
There are circumstances where if you were
really manipulated or forced into breaking
the law and forced into breaking the law is
an even different thing.
Courts can consider that and it can impact
the guilt versus innocence and it can impact
sentencing.
But under federal statutes in this particular
situation, the law wouldn't see the Trump
defense as a valid defense.
It wouldn't see Fox itis and Fox mania as
valid defenses.
Just because a nutty, childish clown tells
you to do something, even if that someone
is the president does not make it a valid
legal defense, particularly when you are dealing
with these specific federal statutes.
But this is sort of a version of stochastic
terrorism.
As I've said before, it's really hard to hold
people accountable for that.
But if you have a large enough audience, if
remember Glenn Beck, when he used to have
I think it was a Fox News or CNN show Glenn
Beck ranting about the Tides Foundation, which
he became obsessed with every day, statistically,
someone in his audience is going to hear that
and say, I'm going to go and do something
about the Tides Foundation.
And case in point, there was a guy arrested
by California Highway Patrol driving to the
Tides Foundation to do who the hell knows
what with a large enough audience when you
start saying someone should do X, and if only
someone did Y, the likelihood that at least
one person in this case, hundreds or thousands
of people will try to do it goes up and up
and up.
It's almost it's kind of like a silly version
of the Nuremberg defense.
The difference being none of these people
are in the chain of command.
The Trump writers were not in the chain of
command where you could even say I was following
orders.
In a sense, there were no risks or punishments
if you just stayed the hell home, if the Kuhnen
shaman said, you know what, that are going
to DCL stay at home, no one was going to punish
him for that.
There was not going to be any risk to doing
that.
He would have been fine.
And so that also further is the reason why
it's not a particularly good defense now,
even if it doesn't make a difference for these
specific people.
The funny or maybe the ironic thing in people
pointing to Trump as the reason why they did
this could be something that comes up in a
Justice Department investigation or a house
congressional investigation into Trump's role.
But I don't expect that will go very far,
at least a holding Donald Trump accountable.
The other possibility is that while claiming
Trump made me do it might make no difference
in their criminal trials.
Civil trials are a whole different thing.
And one lawyer wrote to me and said, the Trump
made me do it.
Defense could be something that plays a role
in a civil trial if there were to be one last
thought.
It is not beyond me.
The irony of people who claim to represent
a political ideology that preaches and values
and prioritizes personal responsibility, who
then get charged with crimes that they did
and immediately claim as their defenses.
Fox News convinced me or Trump made me do
it.
It's pitiful.
It's pitiful and pathetic.
And it is again a reminder that their stated
values and principles are merely stated.
They are not really sincerely held values
and principles.
They abandon them, abandon them instantly
when it's no longer convenient.